for our daily cancellation today we take
into consideration a recent viral video
from a woman who insists that although
she's morbidly obese you must still find
her physically attractive
you're not entitled to your own opinions
or preferences you must
fall madly in love with her this is not
a suggestion but rather a
requirement as she clearly explains
listen
hey bestie you're wrong
i think it's time for another adult
pre-k lesson what do you think
all right turn your listening ears on
you catch a bubble in your mouth
good job okay here's the thing
having a preference is something like
i'm looking for a partner who likes
kayaking
or wakes up early in the morning or
loves pizza
but when your preferences exclude an
entire group of marginalized people
that's problematic
okay that's not nice that's not a
preference if you lump all fat people in
one group together
as though they are not very different
individuals
that's fatphobic just like lumping all
black people in one group and saying i
don't
like black people is racist and lumping
all disabled people in one group and
saying
i don't think people in wheelchairs are
hot is ableist
do you understand what i'm saying no i
don't
okay so well okay so you are allowed to
prefer a partner who likes kayaking
which
thankfully i think lets us off the hook
because something tells me she's not
exactly an avid kayaker
but those loopholes aside it seems that
our friend here has stumbled on a rather
unique pickup line
part of me wishes that i had thought of
this when i was single like ma'am
you are morally obligated to find me
attractive now come and date me at once
lest you be guilty of problematic and
exclusionary behavior
but something tells me i would have uh
uh struck out as badly with that line as
i'm sure she does
the only difference is that i would have
been arrested for harassment and
stalking on top of it
now a few points to make here first of
all this woman and my 12 seconds of
research tells me that her name is lexie
has and the research was just looking at
the bottom of the of the video there
where it says her name
has a she has a she has a problem that
goes beyond her weight
if lexi finds that most people don't
want to be around her it probably is
because of her god-awful personality
i for one would rather take a bath and
battery acid
than be stuck in a room with her for any
length of time
that's got nothing to do with her
appearance it has everything to do with
her demeanor her attitude
tone of voice and just way of being
this is something that anyone who
struggles to find a partner should take
into consideration before wondering
whether you're being discriminated
against based on your physical features
please reflect on the possibility
that you might be a nagging miserable
shrew
now it can be hard even for the most
attractive person to find or at least
maintain
relationships if they have a repulsive
personality
but if you're not a top-notch physical
specimen and most of us aren't
and you also have the character and
general disposition of the wicked witch
of the west
then you you really have put yourself in
a hole with only yourself to blame for
it
second point she says that you aren't
allowed to exclude entire groups of
people
from your sexual preference but that of
course is exactly what a sexual
preference
is that's what any kind of preference is
actually preferences
exclude by definition all preferences do
any preference is exclusionary and
discriminatory that's the whole point
you're preferring one thing over another
or one person over another
as for sexual preference specifically
gay men exclude her because she's a
woman
is she going to berate them for that
well she might i guess as we've
seen for years the left insisted that
sexuality is innate and immutable
it can't be changed and it's not the
result of choice but more recently
they've decided that their own arguments
no longer hold
your sexuality can become problematic if
it excludes
so-called marginalized groups a gay man
who isn't attracted to a woman who
identifies as a man
is now transphobe a straight man who
isn't attracted to a man who identifies
as a woman
is also a transphobe anybody who isn't
attracted to an obese person is fat
phobic
anyone who isn't attracted to shrill
hectoring condescending scolds like lexi
is whatever kind of phobic that applies
to
your sexuality is not your own business
it is not a private matter anymore as
the left had previously insisted
they will decide who you should be
attracted to and quite often
coincidentally enough
the person putting themselves in the
position to make this choice for you
will decide that you should be attracted
to them personally
funny how that works you know it's like
well i've run the numbers and i've done
the calculations and it turns out
that in order to not be a bigot you're
supposed to be turned on by uh
what does it say here oh me sorry i
don't make the rules
well i guess i do actually third point
briefly referring back to the first
um this seems to be something that a lot
of people do even if they aren't on the
left
when people have trouble forming and
maintaining relationships both sexual
and platonic
they develop a victim complex deciding
that the problem
in their personal and romantic lives is
that everyone else is being mean to them
and this only exacerbates the problem
because nobody wants to be around
someone with a victim complex even
people with victim complexes
don't want to be around other people
with victim complexes in fact people
with victim complexes especially don't
want to be around other people to victim
complexes
because then it becomes a zero-sum game
a sort of victimhood competition
the self-determined victim becomes all
the more isolated as a result
and their victim mentality only hardens
and spreads and metastasizes over time
so if you're looking around and finding
that most people don't want to be around
you
don't find you appealing or attractive
on any level
you could start pointing fingers and
making demands or you can begin the
difficult work of
changing yourself and this process
should be one that includes both the
exterior and the interior both physical
and spiritual
although this is hard and painful and it
requires the kind of honest
self-assessment that most people don't
have the wherewithal to conduct
the good thing is that you actually have
control over yourself
yourself is a thing you can change by
the grace of god
you can't really force anyone else to
change
all you could do is scream at them as
they back ever farther away
until you're all alone yelling into the
void
it's up to you which strategy you choose
we know which one lexi has chosen and
for that reason today she is of course
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated